focusing on this 10th anniversary and
I'll tell you secret we have a cool logo
that says Marvel Studios the first 10
years that was directly ripped off of my
very positive memories of 1987 and Star
Wars the first 10 years there wasn't
much entering the dark times as
collectors call it when there wasn't a
whole lot of stuff hmm den domes came up
I remember thinking the Star Wars figure
on a shelf then it was not great but we
were desperately dark in the dark time
but Lucasfilm acknowledged the 10th
anniversary and they called it the first
10 years which got me excited as a fan
to think will be more must be the first
of many mm-hmm and it took many years to
fulfill that but as we were saying let's
celebrate our 10th anniversary and I was
trying to come up with a tagline we just
stole from the Star Wars anniversary
amazing what I love is you were brought
on specifically because you had already
known this universe you were already
invested in Marvel comic I knew these
types of characters I didn't know as
much as I know now but I knew I wanted
to work on these kind of movies mainly
because of this movie and over the years
the actors have become marquee names
because Robert Downey jr. and Chris
Evans and Hemsworth and Scarlett have
all become mega stars but at the time we
really believed let's find the best
actors for the parts not dissimilar from
a little movie 40 years ago that found
great new actors who became icons and
stars you cite as sort of an influence
for you a book that's very important to
a lot of people which is the source book
for the Star Wars tabletop game
absolutely I was never a big role play
gamer but when that came out I was the
kid that kept playing with Star Wars
toys maybe a little longer than the
other kids did saved so I was 10 years
old when Jedi came out had all those the
power of the force line came out 85 so
there hadn't been a Star Wars movie in a
couple of years and as you know that's
when Kenner stopped making the power of
the force line was the last line they
did I got all those and I was like what
where's everybody going yeah where's
everybody going and I think it was
around that time probably in 85 that the
West End games came out and I read it
cover to cover and it was a wealth of
new information and one of the great
things about Star Wars and one things I
think that's great about the Marvel
characters from the comics and what we
try to emulate in the movies is if
you're the kind of person wants to go
see on an opening weekend our job is to
make sure you have a great time if you
want to see the second time our job is
to make sure there's more there third
fourth fifth time still more there and
even the deeper you go there'll be
things
to reward you and I learned that
directly from Star Wars and from those
West End source books yeah reading about
the real names of all the cantina
characters I didn't know they had names
this is unbelievable and then when the
power of the force to light came at 95
learning more names and more backstories
hammerhead has real name walrus man his
real name and real backstory in real
history and keeping track of that is not
as complicated I think for us as it is
for Star Wars we've got ten years
starters got 40-plus years but it really
comes out of each individual film and
what's best for each individual story
that we're telling you thank you
congratulations on the first ten years
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have to talk about Kevin Feige doing a
Star Wars movie I know you have
thousands of questions what does this
mean what is the movie gonna be like is
it gonna be a new trilogy is it just
gonna be a one-off film why of all
people did they pick Kevin Feige to make
a Star Wars movie so some of these
questions are actually really easy to
answer but we'll break it down we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best theory about what Star Wars
Episode 10 is going to be about so just
to be clear they did not specify when
Kevin Feige Star Wars movie is supposed
to come out the next new Star Wars movie
after Star Wars Episode nine isn't
supposed to premiere till 2022 so
there'll be a three year break in Star
Wars movies all the Disney Plus Star
Wars series like the Mandalorian and the
other series at the ob1 series they're
developing those will fill the gap in
between so for the next couple of years
that'll be the new Star Wars content
that we're getting there's still
technically three other different
trilogies that are being developed by
different groups
there's the Knights of the Old Republic
trilogy that's being developed by
someone then there's the Benioff in a
wise trilogy they're not doing Knights
of the Old Republic whatever they're
doing it's gonna be completely different
then Rian Johnson is also doing a
separate trilogy there are so many
people that they just named are
developing Star Wars movies Kevin Feige
is just the newest part of that bunch so
his movie won't have anything to do with
what's going on with these other groups
developing star wars movies that
interview with him where he's geeking
out about Star Wars and talking about
his history with the franchise it sounds
like he's almost a bigger fan of Star
Wars than he is of Marvel stuff but of
course he is the boss at Marvel so he
has to be the biggest fan of Marvel
right now but I think a lot of people
just saw the news headlines the Kevin
Feige was tagged by Disney to do a Star
Wars movie in
didn't really understand his history
with the Star Wars franchise
I'll read the official news release
about this this is actually coming from
his boss that's right Kevin Feige does
have a boss at Disney so it says we are
excited about the projects Kathleen
Kennedy and the Lucasfilm team are
working on not only in terms of Star
Wars but also Indiana Jones and reaching
into other parts of the company
including children of blood and bone
with Emma Watts and Fox with the close
of the Skywalker saga Kathy is pursuing
a new era in Star Wars storytelling in
knowing what a die-hard fan Kevin is it
made sense for these two extraordinary
producers to work on a Star Wars film
together so if it wasn't clear Kevin
Feige is only producing a new Star Wars
film he'll get somebody else to direct
it somebody else to write it and
obviously it's gonna take a while before
that happens because first he has to
come up with the story that he wants to
tell then find the people to tell that
story
everybody queue up that clip of Patton
Oswalt's filibuster Star Wars pitch for
the marble x-men crossover we are
uncannily close to that now even though
of course this is just gonna be a Star
Wars film it's not gonna have anything
to do with Marvel coming into Star Wars
please allow me because we see fan OHS
if he holds the reality gem that means
he can jump from different realities
this will be our link from to the Marvel
Universe from the Star Wars universe
there was a report that he does have a
Marvel actor for a very specific Star
Wars role but no idea what that role
would be or whether his movie would deal
with pre-existing characters we've
already met or brand-new characters
we've never seen before but because in
the news released they specifically
referred to the end of the Skywalker
saga in a new era in Star Wars
storytelling it sounds like Kevin Feige
Star Wars movie will be set after the
events of the rise of Skywalker with a
completely new group of characters that
we've never seen before I think the only
way his movie winds up being Star Wars
Episode 10 is if they aren't quite as
sure with what the other groups are
developing in terms of their Star Wars
trilogies I would love for Star Wars
Episode 10 to be the first in a new
Knights of the Old Republic trilogy but
they probably won't announce what Star
Wars Episode 10 is going to be until
they actually start casting it to the
last possible second that they can
reveal something if you're worried at
all about Kevin Feige in the Marvel
people stepping into Star Wars like
there are a lot of people who are
fans of Star Wars and don't like the
Marvel movies you just have to
understand what a huge geek about Star
Wars Kevin Feige is if he were not
working in Hollywood he would be running
his own YouTube channel talking about
Star Wars toy collecting like during the
interview that I tagged at the beginning
of this video he talks about collecting
Star Wars toys during the dark times
when there was no new Star Wars movies
and it was before they started doing the
expanded universe books back in 2016
there was an interview he did for
Captain America's Civil War where he
talks about being a Star Wars fan he
said I have two jobs running Marvel
being a big Marvel fan and being a Star
Wars nerd those are my two jobs my house
is full of Star Wars so I'm as big a
star wars fan as there is what's great
is I've often said that if I wasn't
making these Marvel movies I'd be
waiting in line to see them but as this
happens to you two you're behind the
scenes you see things and you're losing
the purity of the experience of being a
film fan I've not lost that with all the
Star Wars and I don't want to lose that
I saw the force awakens at the premiere
and I probably knew even less than you
about the movie remember Kevin Feige is
a really powerful person if he wanted
details on new Star Wars movies he could
get them then he goes on to say the
closest I have is sometimes we were
doing Doctor Strange in the vicinity
where there were some Star Wars things
starting to happen and sometimes I try
to peek around the corner and see a
piece of plywood being turned into a
ship of some kind and geek out so I like
being the star wars fan that I am
there's another funny story that Geoff
Johns told early in their career they
both worked for dick Donner and Lauren
Shuler Donner production company you
have to imagine they're in their mid to
late 20s
Kevin Feige actually built himself an
illegal shed in his back yard to house
his massive Star Wars toy collection
this is Jeff John's telling that story I
love it because I remember when you
built that shed on top of your apartment
building I didn't know if that was legal
Star Trek figures toys I think the
takeaway from all this is that a lot of
people just didn't realize what a big
star wars fan he is and how close he is
to the franchise because most people
only talk about Marvel stuff when they
think of Kevin Feige so I have no doubt
that he treats the franchise with
reverence in whatever store he does tell
it'll at least be entertaining in a fun
movie
we have no idea who the characters are
going to be yet it'll probably be a year
or so before we get any more news about
what that's going to be usually the
timeline is they announce producers come
on to a project then about a year later
they hire the directors they hire the
writers they work for another year on
the story then they go into production
so it's gonna be a while before we get a
whole bunch of news about this brand new
Kevin Feige Marvel Star Wars movie but
if there was any confusion about it it's
not Marvel crossing over with Star Wars
it's just Kevin Feige is creative making
a Star Wars project fun fact - because
he's such a big star Wars fan a couple
of years ago he almost left Marvel
because there was so much friction
between him in the Marvel CEO so he
almost decided to quit Marvel Studios at
that time he was also considering taking
over Star Wars obviously that didn't
happen in Disney cleaned up the friction
between him and the Marvel CEO in Marvel
Studios spun off into his own little
entity so now he gets to do whatever he
wants with the Marvel movies but for a
very brief period you almost had Kevin
Feige running Star Wars there'll be a
whole bunch more Star Wars Episode nine
trailers coming in the next couple of
months
and obviously the mandalorian will be
starting on November 12th I will be
doing weekly episode videos for that in
Easter eggs
congratulations Z rizal you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for the deleted
spider-man far from home post credits
scene and new venom - and click here for
my new Avengers infinity Saga trailer
and Marvel pays for trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
may the force be with you
[Music]